sometimes you just need a real honest
file on disk but in serverless Computing
like with Cloud run you don't have a
traditional server with a regular file
system what if we need to process files
well often we only need a file system
while we're handling a request and
cloudron has one your Cloud run service
can write files to a temporary file
system that is reset between requests
this is useful if you need to write a
file that you later copy to cloud
storage or if you need to download a big
file for processing or if you use a
library that can only work with files on
disk because cloudrun is serverless you
don't have to worry about the disk
filling up over time and as traffic
increases Google will spin up new
instances for you giving you greater
scalability what if you need files to
stick around between requests stay tuned
I'll bring that up in a future episode
now go and build great scalable apps
that use the temporary file system